[Music]
claire is in denver colorado hey claire
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
okay so i have a little bit of like a
double life going on um i am an
accountant and i'm also a professional
mma fighter
and i'm having some you're an accountant
wait a minute i don't want to drive past
that too quick
you're an accountant by day and an mma
fighter by night
yeah it's like a superhero
yeah like a superhero clark kent
normally it's normally a good balance
but uh yeah yeah so so what happened
this week is um
so i had a little bit of a head trauma
nothing super serious but it was
unexpected and i was having some side
effects so i had to go see a specialist
um so i went to see a neurologist and
basically um all of a sudden i had a
2500 bill
uh and that's for my whole treatment
like it was actually a very reasonable
price and whatnot um but i only had a
thousand dollars in my emergency fund
so i used that and then i had to
unfreeze the credit card that i was
paying off and put the balance on that
card which you know is not something i
was wanting to do
and i'm still paying off debt i've got
about 22 000
left in my debt uh
so yeah so at this point um i'm just
trying to figure out if maybe i need to
pad my emergency fund a little more for
the time being uh before i can get to
that third baby step or how i should
handle this
wow
okay so
uh
head trauma is not an unexpected event
when you are an mma fighter
right that's a predictable event
right i mean logically yeah
i've never participated but i've watched
what you do and
i'm scared of you right now
[Laughter]
uh so uh uh
have you made money
fighting so i'm at the point right now
um i'm actually in a really good spot i
fight for a good organization but uh the
way mma works is you're making very
little money until you're making a lot
of money so right now um from fighting i
make about 15 grand a year okay
let's bank that as a business
let's bank that to the side as a
business
and hope you break even with medical
bills
right so take a take run your life on
your accounting income
and set the mma
aside as a as a small business idea and
say this small business is going to
break even if we're lucky
okay okay
and then you can just bank that money
and they and instead of changing the
baby steps let's just qualify this as a
small business because it legitimately
is it's a side hustle
and uh you know and so how long have you
been doing this i'm interested
uh i have been doing this for i think
about six years all together i had a
long amateur career and i'm a
professional so it's been a journey
so how long have you been pro
i've been pro uh for about i think it's
only been about two years right now so
far how old are you
i'm 25. okay
so you you figure you got what five
years on the ring more
you know i'm hoping ten more years so
that's also why i'm taking this brain
stuff real seriously and you know after
that i want to do accounting for the
rest of my life so
yeah so you really can't afford to get
your eggs scrambled doing that then
right yeah exactly exactly i just wonder
i've gotta ask this is quick
do you allow the frustration of the
accounting to get you mad enough to
punch somebody or do you love the
accounting
you know i really love the account i
know i honestly
that's great
that is so fun yeah and so you're so
you're you're probably a very technical
fighter then
yes yes exactly yeah very cool well fun
claire well that's neat first first mma
fighter question we've had so yeah
you're you're the first shooter
i'll have more moving forward especially
when the money starts rolling in i'll
probably remember the call because it's
it's it's not one i get all the time so
you call back anytime we can help that's
interesting
very fun